de la loi sru oui et pas que c'est une
remise en cause en fait de notre
histoire de france
il faut bien comprendre qu'on a un
modèle social et le modèle du logement
unique en europe
il repose sur deux pieds la jambe public
et l'argent privé ce qui nous a permis
la jeune public de répondre à une crise
du logement notamment en 1954 avec
l'appel de l'abbé pierre
la jeune public a pu permettre la
construction de logements aussi en 2008
avec la crise des sub prime
je rappelle que les organismes hlm ont
déstocké cinquante mille logements
sociaux auprès des promoteurs
sinon il mettait la clé sous la porte et
donc la loi sru
ç'a permis quoi ça permis de construire
entre 500 et 600 mille logements depuis
18 ans et donc c'est cette remise en
cause de cette jambe public on est en
train de libéraliser de privatiser de
donner toutes les clés du logement
social au privé est en réalité on va pas
répondre à une crise du logement qui une
des premières préoccupations des
françaises et des français
aujourd'hui à 4 millions de françaises
et français qui sont mal logées dans 900
mille sont privées de logement
individuel 12 millions de françaises et
français sont en cause mais oui mais il
s'en défend mais par plusieurs par
plusieurs choses
d'abord on va imposer de vendre 40 mille
logements sociaux holtz et ça va
dégrader un certain nombre de logements
et de parc de logements sociaux parce
que c'est pour pouvoir en construire
deux oui mais c'est un désengagement de
l'état parce qu'on dit clairement c'est
cette vente qui va permettre de dégager
de dieu de l'arrangement a vendu à la 3
construit mais oui mais c'est un
désengagement encore de l'état parce que
c'est cédant que ça fait des
copropriétés dégradées
regardez dans certains quartiers
populaires la vente de ces logements
et c'est une dégradation totale des
conditions de vie des gens et donc la
loi sru elle est attaquée à sa racine
parce que vous l'avez dit dans notre
reportage l'article 24
c'est à dire que pour un certain nombre
de communes qui ne respectent déjà pas
la loi sru
ils ont vendra qu'on vendra le logement
on va passer de cinq à dix ans c'est à
dire que pendant dix ans ça sera encore
considéré comme un logement social donc
qu'est ce qu'ils vont dire les communes
qui ne respectent pas
entre elles vont bon train termites
qu'elles vont vendre construction elles
vont vendre le logement social et dire
regardez on respecte la loi et en
réalité on ne construira plus le
logement social
il ya une crise du logement il ya une
crise de la cherté du logement
il ya besoin de plus de logement social
dans notre pays et qui soit mieux
répartie sur nos territoires
on ne répondra pas cette crise là je le
disais 4 millions de mal-logés 12
millions en situation de précarité
notamment énergétiques mais c'est un
fait c'est sur quatre le budget logement
de la france c'est 42 milliards d'euros
est ce que jacques mézard à tort de
vouloir que ce secteur s'autofinance
mais écoutez le logement social c'est
quoi c'est pas le logement que pour les
pauvres c'est le logement pour 72 % des
salariés c'est le logement pour toutes
et tous
si une garantie de la mixité sociale et
donc il ya besoin un certain nombre de
personnes ne peuvent pas se loger dans
le parc privé
moi je le vois un certain nombre par
exemple j'habite à blanc mesnil ne
peuvent pas se loger dans le parc privé
il ya besoin de logement social en 2016
y avait pris 2,2 millions de demandeurs
de logement social vous savez combien
ont été répondues 500 milles c'est à
dire que 1 million 500 mille françaises
et français
on était en attente d'un logement social
en france en 2016 et ces chiffres
continuent de croître d'année en année
parce que il ya un besoin fort de
logement social est en vérité il ya une
décroissance de la construction de
logement social donc c'est ça la réalité
juste un mot sur un autre point
polémique de la loi est la réduction de
100 % à 10 % du nombre de logements
neufs accessibles aux handicapés
c'est là aussi une mise en mal de la loi
handicap évidemment parce que c'est ça
qui a il ya choqué tout le monde il ya
la loi sru on vient d'en parler à
quelqu'un qui atteint logement social et
qui en situation de handicap
aujourd'hui bon il ya déjà cette
difficulté de pouvoir accéder à un
logement social je vais le dire sur 4
peut avoir un logement social ça veut
dire que trois sur quatre sont en
attente
et quand on est en situation de handicap
on va avoir la double peine parce qu'il
faudra attendre plus qu'un logement
social qui soient adaptées pour le
handicap soit libéré donc ça sera la
double peine est en réalité nous avons
posé la question hier avec dominique
watrin sénateur communiste du
pas-de-calais au gouvernement nous leur
avons dit comment vous allez faire ils
ont dit
vous inquiétez pas qu'il y aura un
logement social de libre et qui sera pas
adapté
eh bien il faudra il faudra le financer
on lui a posé la question mais qui le
financera le parc social où les gens en
situation de handicap
on n'a pas eu de réponse donc ça c'est
une vraie véritable question voilà je
c'est une loi mauvaise de bout en bout